[Music]
there's scientific consensus on a lot of
things on climate change the best
scientists in the world are all telling
us that our activities are changing the
climate on HPV vaccine the majority of
cervical cancer cases are avoidable if
we vaccinate against HPV and that deeply
burying nuclear waste is a good
long-term solution so you would think
that the public could agree on these
issues in many ways one would hope that
that's true right the information that
we learn about science ends up getting
filtered through our prior beliefs
through our values through our religious
views our ideologies and as a result the
exact same piece of scientific
information means very different things
to different people
compliance for mandatory vaccinations is
about 90% in the US but the HPV vaccine
that protects against cancer from a
sexually transmitted virus is only
mandatory in three places you can frame
HPV in two ways you can either see this
as a vaccine against cancer and leave it
at that or you can see it as a vaccine
that as some people saw it as it was
rolled out in Texas and elsewhere that
would lead to promiscuity so why do we
disagree on scientific consensus what's
important to keep in mind here when we
process new information the way we as
human beings do that we put them on
mental shelves I don't look at every
piece of information as if it's the
first thing I've ever seen I basically
have in my head a number of mental
shelves that allow me to quickly
categorize new information so HPV
vaccine the HPV vaccine is a great
example because then I can either put
that on a curing cancer shelf or I can
put that on a on a sexual intercourse
among minors or among people who we
think shouldn't have that yet shelf
let's see how that works we're going to
introduce you to two composite
characters we're calling them Marcia
Marie and they are proxies for a whole
bunch of studies that have looked at
this issue first meet Marsha she's a
working professional college-educated
she has two children and she's
scientifically literate now meet Marie
hi everyone she's a working professional
college-educated she has two children
and is also scientifically literate they
are alike but so different the
government should stop telling people
how to live their lives the government
should put limits on the choices of
individuals so they don't get in the way
of what's good for society it's not the
government's business to make laws that
keep people from hurting themselves the
government should do more to advance
society's goals even if that means
limiting the freedom and choices of
individuals their cultural and political
outlooks on the world differ and
researchers have labels to describe them
Marsha has a hierarchical and
individualist view of the world on
climate change I really don't think
there's a climate problem and certainly
not man-made the HPV vaccine I mean I
don't know why my daughter has to be
vaccinated against a sexually
transmitted virus when she's only 12 and
she thinks it's safe to bury nuclear
waste it's going to be buried very deep
underground I don't see why Marie's
worldview is egalitarian and
communitarian on climate change of
course climate change is happening and
we humans are making it worse on the HPV
vaccine as soon as I can protect my
child from diseases the better and
unburying nuclear waste I'm really
skeptical about burying it there are
earthquakes happening in places we never
thought
their worldview affects how they assess
risk so cultural cognition is a version
of what's what what we've known in
psychology for a long time as motivated
reasoning and motivated reasoning says
we as human beings don't reason in a
perfectly objective or neutral way
scientific information may be fact-based
or neutral but how we interpret that
information is not we assimilate reality
into our biased worldview we don't
adjust our worldview based on the
reality but we we adjust reality based
on our worldview in fact the more
scientifically literate the more you
stick to your beliefs we protect our
identities it is all about identity
protection if I'm a strong conservative
or strong liberal I don't want facts to
constantly challenge what I really hold
deep down to be true in an increasingly
politically polarized world how do we
fix this problem there's a consensus in
this room that science is good it's not
just interesting but on the whole it's
good but at the same time we all know
that there's a conversation about
science taking part in our society that
also is divisive that people get angry
about science that some of the divides
in society that already exist are
enhanced and deepened over questions
related to science and what we want to
investigate tonight is why is that and
what can we do about that let's meet our
panelists our first participant is a
professor of law and psychology at Yale
Law School who previously clerked for
Supreme Court Justice Thurgood Marshall
he is one of the country's leading
researchers on risk perception and as
part of the cultural cognition project
where scholars study how a cultural
value shapes public risk perceptions and
related policy beliefs a bona fide
expert in the science of science
communication please welcome Dan kahan
our next guest is a Nobel laureate
geneticist and cell biologist he has
been president of the Rockefeller
University here in New York he is now
president of the Royal Society of London
sorry he stopped doing that in 2015 but
he was and a member of the UK prime
minister scientific advisory committee
at present he is the director of the
Francis Crick Institute in London
please welcome sir Paul nurse our next
guest is responsible for a federal
agency that has a budget of 7.5 billion
dollars devoted to science before that
she was president of Purdue University
she's been a group leader at Los Alamos
National Lab an astrophysicist
she became NASA's first female chief
scientist please welcome the director of
the National Science Foundation France
córdova
and our final panelist is a professor of
physics and mathematics at Columbia
University known for groundbreaking
discoveries in the area of super string
theory he is a best-selling author has
hosted two award-winning series on Nova
his TED talk making sense of string
theory has been viewed over four million
times and a co-founder of the world
science festival which is now in its
tenth year please welcome Brian Greene
so on this question of polarization of
science I want to go straight to Sir
Paul you last year produced a BBC
program called science under attack
which I strongly recommend science
created our modern world so I want to
understand why science appears to be
under such attack
and whether we scientists are partly to
blame what are the battle lines of this
attack that you were talking about well
I think we do have an issue that is of
significance and that is when science
comes up against politics ideology and
religion then we can get quite a potent
brew and in certain issues and we saw
them in the introduction climate change
will be one vaccination GMOs these are
particularly toxic in the public mind
and really what I wanted to communicate
with that program was that we should
initially look at the science first if
we can do that because obviously
psychologically we're looking at
everything at the same time but we
should look at the science first rather
then first of all take an ideological or
political position and the game we saw
that with the two individuals you add up
there and then cherry-pick the science
data to fit with your ideology or
religion or politics or whatever that is
the wrong way to do things
and that will lead to a very poor use of
science and I think that's a critical
point that we should try and address
perhaps this evening do you need to be a
scientist to know how to do that you
need to be a scientist to produce that
information but we need to have a
culture that will recognize that that is
the right way to do that and of course
what that means is that we need to have
a society which respects the process of
science that's a little bit abstract and
perhaps difficult to to win hearts and
minds on and we also need to have a
trust in the scientists who are carrying
it out so it's a a trust in a process
it's a trust in the scientists but we
have to recognize scientists are human
beings they are not perfect and they
will make mistakes everything isn't
perfect that they do and sometimes
there's even earn fraud for example we
also have to understand but not all
science is on completely secure
foundations if we look at Newton's laws
of physics they've been around for three
centuries they've been tested repeatedly
we can tell where a planet will be
within centimetres with great accuracy
if on the other hand you're are you ask
a scientist whether the next Ebola
epidemic is going to kill 100 million
people or 1 million people that's a much
more difficult question to answer and
science is often I prefer to use the
term tentative knowledge knowledge that
is evolving and developing now if we
have those two things together that is
tentative knowledge and the human
frailty that can produce incorrect
science that leaves gaps and spaces
which can be exploited by those with
political and ideological and even
religious opinions to cherry pick what
they want and we need to understand all
of that process if we're going to get
this right France córdova you've
graduated from Stanford not planning to
go into science at all you're you
graduated with a degree in what English
literature so what happened what
happened to me as I was inspired by a
public television show to become a
scientist I I was inspired by the moon
landing of course that was very dramatic
and all but but it was really the the
public television show where they
featured scientists talking about these
strange new stars they had discovered
called neutron stars and it so
captivated me and I thought what would I
what would I ultimately like to do and
give myself over to growing up and and I
thought that's what I want to be I want
to be a scientist so so I just went into
I just knocked on the doors actually of
some of the people who were in featured
in that movie at MIT so you make this
transition from the world of not being a
scientist into the world of being a
scientist you were that Lee
person who became the professional what
what what was the thing that you needed
to absorb about how science works that
you think maybe isn't so obvious to a
regular folks I always think of science
as an exploration of just going to the
next frontier the next step and that's
the unknown and you never and that's a
constantly evolving process so I I
wouldn't expect science to yield I
expect it to reveal itself little by
little as one explores it just like any
new frontier does but never would you
would you know everything the universe
is so vast and there's so many things
that we have no knowledge of which
you're constantly tried to penetrate and
and go deeper into that into that
unknown that that's the part that drives
me I think it drives the public as well
I I think they're there but they have
more curiosity than we give them growing
of public let me take it to Brian here
you you really are and I mean this in a
very positive way a popularizer of
science with the television programs
that you do but that means that you need
to find a language to speak to people
who may not understand the subtleties
and it's sort of the same question to
you and again it's jump bouncing off of
what Paul said this this whether people
really grasp what the scientific process
is about yeah so I'm gonna give you two
answers one from the standpoint of the
science itself and the other from
communicating the ideas and I think from
the standpoint of the science I think
there is a general resistance to being
in a place of uncertainty and what
happens is when there's a glimmer of
uncertainty it turns into a general
impression that the scientists don't
know what they're talking about and
therefore I don't really need to pay
attention to what's going on right now
because they haven't figured out they
don't know what's going on I think a
good example of that which takes us a
little bit away from the political
sphere which I think makes this nice
little laboratory setting there's an
article in Scientific American in
February not to do with climate change
or vaccines but having to do with
cosmology right and there's the article
is basically challenging the per
availing view of cosmology and in
response to that a number of scientists
who believe strongly in the prevailing
view wrote a letter to the editor
expressing their view so this has now
come out as a disagreement and what I
expected would happen has happened
because I've spoken to a number of
people during this festival who have
come up to me with the general
impression
ah you the cosmology is now falling
apart nobody knows anything that's going
on when it comes to cosmology and the
fact is the only reason why we're having
this controversy is because we
understand things so spectacularly well
that now we can ask the kinds of
questions that we couldn't even ask
twenty years ago and it's in those fine
details that certain issues are starting
to bubble up and different perspectives
are coming to the fore so it's a
beautiful example of the scientific
process we're now through observation
and experiment we have a deeper handle
on what's going on allowing us to go
further in ideas but you get it out
there into the general public say
through say Scientific American the
impression that it leaves is radically
different from the actual state of the
field
denne gone first of all tell us what you
do for a living I'm not sure I do
anything for a living I haven't worked
since June 30th 1993 which is the last
day before my first academic appointment
became operative I disobey but I guess
the work I do is to study science
communication and risk perception but to
try to understand the psychological
dynamics that account for the kind of
political polarization that was featured
in our opening and then to try to come
up with mechanisms or strategies that
can make that less disruptive of what
otherwise be the great benefit we get
from all we know so so what are the
ruling theories on again the situation
that Paul laid out well and so the one
thing is I I don't think we should
understand this to be a consequence of
limitations and people's ability to
understand science and maybe problems
they have with uncertainty
the most striking things about this
research is that the higher people score
on any measure of science comprehension
and critical thinking the more intensely
they're processing the information in a
way that conforms it to the beliefs that
predominate in their group
can you so that people the people who
are highest in science literacy the
people who are highest in critical
reasoning they're the ones who most
aggressively construe information about
these contested issues in a way that
conduces to beliefs that are in line
with the ones in their group right so
this is these aren't people who are just
confused about science the I mean it's
actually a tragic thing that they're
using their reason in that way to try to
understand the evidence and the facts in
ways that confirm what their group
believes but the problem isn't any kind
of ignorance about science at all
when this happens people who have very
acute reasoning processes they're
applying their cognitive resources to
get the answers that support their group
I wouldn't come back like that welcome
back to what the specifics of your
research but does that surprise
everybody else oh I do find it slightly
surprising although it aligns with
certain things so I that would make a
lot of sense to me when the scientific
issues directly impact on things that
have relevance to our lives because then
as you say if a certain kind of
scientific insight might lead to a
policy that goes against how you want
the world to be I can imagine that all
sorts of other issues bubble up and
cause you to as we discussed before
cherry-pick and order that it won't
yield that kind of an outcome but have
you done studies where people are
presented with scientific issues that
that don't have that oh well you know
that we and we should be be realistic
about this most issues don't have this
problem there are many many more science
insights about risk that don't involve
this perverse effect of people with
different values forming different views
at all much less people who have
different values and the most developed
capacity for science comprehension
polarizing all the more
these are issues that are pathological
on both in the sense of being bad but
also being rare and if you don't
understand the the the great class of
issues that don't have this feature
you'll never actually be able to have
good hypotheses about what causes it and
maybe just one a quick example on this
um this isn't in effect science in a
really consequential way and we should
be concerned about it but these dynamics
are not specific to science if I took I
was a Murray and Marcia what would if I
took the and I showed them a video of a
protest and I told them that the the
political protest was at an abortion
clinic then they would come out with
very different views about what they saw
happening there was somebody blocking
somebody was somebody hitting somebody
else over that the head with a sign if I
told him it was a military recruitment
center protest then they would flip
around and see the exactly the opposite
I mean I don't know about them as
individuals but groups of people who
have their values so when facts become
entangled in these group identities so
that positions are like badges of
identity and and and vouchers of loyalty
to the group people disagree on the
facts
that's not limited to science but your
the implication of what you're saying is
that this that there is no solution in
just giving people the facts that that's
not going to work just giving people the
facts that they're going to selectively
credit and discredit the information and
the patterns that reinforce their group
beliefs and the better they are at
critical reasoning the more successful
successfully they're gonna do that
that's not the information that they're
missing are you personally immune from
that yes I am personally I did bone
marrow transplant from Brian but
actually thank you for that no I don't
think I'm immune from it
and I think too if I put it this way
probably most people recognize that you
know this could be happening to me on
certain issues but you don't know win
right we say that people are
cherry-picking but they're not doing it
consciously they're doing it
unconsciously Paul again to go back to
the documentary that you did you talked
with a couple of activists in the UK who
have taken the position that climate
science is not proven ever established
and in fact it's very dubious
proposition and you sat there and it's
clear what you think the truth is and
you sat there and you let them tell you
that you were wrong and one of them
certainly was not a scientist at all one
of them was a journalist who when you
asked him what studies he read said I
don't read studies I read the studies I
read reviews of studies that other
people do and so you had a very very
pleasant exchange in which the you you
allowed the idea to get across that you
the two of you have equal standing in
that conversation well do you have equal
standing in that conversation and did
you have to go outside and and
and scream after you talk to that guy
well you know um I was rather wicked in
that conversation because I realized I
was dealing with an individual who did
not believe the climate was changing
certainly didn't believe human activity
had in the role in it he came at it
through his own politics and ideology
which I'll talk a little bit about in in
a moment and he had supreme
self-confidence and he was so used to
people shouting at him and then he could
get into a fight that as you saw I just
listened politely until he hung himself
and I think sometimes the consensual
position can be criticized when in fact
it is most likely to be the correct
position yeah should we talk about you
talk about Climategate because I I mean
I I don't I don't accept your analogy
really IIIi think it's uh what are folks
like you scientists supposed to do in
the face of people who haven't who are
not scientists who perhaps do or do not
understand the scientific process
who simply tell you that you are wrong
and that there's a controversy well two
sides of a story and I do have some
thoughts about this I think the the
first position that scientists should
take is actually to listen to what they
have to say and see whether there is a
way that you can reason and discuss it
you shouldn't automatically assume that
it is impossible to have dialogue and
debate in the issue of climate change
you can understand why there's a range
of views it's a very complex subject
it's one that is very data written it's
the models are difficult to do there are
these holes that people can occupy which
because there are gaps in the science
and what has emerged there in climate
change is something that I think is
really quite interesting because there
is some debate about the science but
what I think influence is it most is
what do you do if there really is
climate change being caused by human
intervention because what you do is very
significant for individuals beliefs
because the only way you can deal with
it is something like the Paris agreement
which requires agreement across
countries top down doesn't allow the
individual or the company or even the
state of a country to find their own way
it requires collective action and that
collective action is an anaphora to
those of a certain political event and a
certain ideology on the other hand for
another section of society it's actually
the way they think and the way they like
to think about issues that means that
the science problem turns into a
political problem because the the minds
are lined up really on politics rather
than the science and then you get all
the dirtiness of political discussion
being thrown at the science and I think
that is from my amateurish view of this
has been the real problem
problem here it's become a political
issue and the science is refracted
through those politics we we are we are
talking about polarization but there's
actually evidence that there's a sort of
almost a sort of vast silent majority of
citizens who are behind science I mean
they're they're surveys done where the
question was whether the federal
government US federal government should
even fund science and as you can see
that that orange overwhelming support
for science on the part of the general
public and then a second question was
asked about whether there's enough money
going to science and again surprisingly
the majority of the public said there's
not enough money being spent on science
we should really be cautious not to
characterize this kind of disagreement
as the people who believe in science and
the people who don't how should we first
of all everybody as those graphics were
helping us to see has a very a very
positive views of science they're just
as confused or just as much in a state
of polarization over what the majority
of scientists say are over scientific
consensus as they are on the facts of
whether a global warming is happening or
whether deep geological isolation of
nuclear wastes is a sensible idea those
were examples actually that we used in
an experiment to test whether people
could recognize scientific expertise and
it turns out that people will recognize
a scientist as an expert if that person
has the same view as as their group on
an issue like an etiological isolation
of nuclear waste or climate change so
they're engaged in a kind of bias
sampling but at the end both sides say
that scientific consensus is on their
side
this is like nations going to war saying
well god is on our side
right nobody's out there saying screw
the scientists not in the general public
at least we have another graph that
takes a look in fact that public trust I
believe is the topic in in scientists
and medical scientists which may or may
not come up with that's the pew attacked
the the GSS the General Social Survey
has been doing this for 40 years science
is always second out of 13 institutions
sometimes it's the military
sometimes it's a medical profession but
it's always been second and it's been
second for both Republicans and
Democrats Republicans trusted the
science community during the Reagan
administration more than it trusted the
executive branch people who are
religious in nature trust science more
than they say they trust organized
clergy so we're not a society where
people are questioning questioning
whether but they have a hard time
figuring out what scientists believe on
some of these issues Brian um you're
you're in primarily the physical science
physical physics and the physical
sciences is it a different kind of do
you face these kinds of controversies in
the same sort of way I know you told the
story you told before but it doesn't get
as politicized well no I I feel I feel
that we're in a fortunate position
because most of the people are spending
their energy fighting against these
folks you know in the biology and
climate era they haven't sort of gotten
to physics yet maybe that happens you
know in the future and it's largely
again because of what we're doing
doesn't have a direct impact on policy
that has something where one can
tangibly see it'll affect their life in
one way or another
and and you know aligned with that you
know relevant to the question you asked
before again in terms of quantum
mechanics and general relativity say
these are these are complex and rich and
deep subjects but in a way they're very
simple in that there aren't a lot of
moving parts it comes to climate change
goodness gracious let me let me give you
an example you know I've been asked to
be on programs to talk about climate
change I don't do it you know why I
don't do it I don't feel like I have a
grasp of the science at a deep enough
level where if there's somebody really
good from the other side that they won't
be able to destroy me
whereas I know with almost certainty
that that will not happen if it's a
discussion about quantum mechanics or
unified theory or general relativity
so I feel completely comfortable
discussing that with anybody regardless
of how skeptical they might be but
climate is such a complex subject that
even for a scientist it's difficult i I
actually tried to start to read the
literature so let me educate myself once
and for all
so I can just handle all these climate
issues
straight out and I start to read the
papers and a week or two in them like I
can't do this this is gonna take up my
entire life because it is so complicated
now again that's not to say that I am a
skeptic it's to say that there's so many
moving parts that to be able to rebut
any argument that comes out you requires
a level of understanding and a depth of
understanding that's difficult to
achieve whereas in the physical sciences
go through your the Graduate School
you're there you know yeah that's that's
the difference Paul take climate change
than if it is so complicated that even
the brilliant Brian Green stopped after
a couple of weeks what does everybody
else supposed to do in figuring out what
their position is well as I was saying
about climate change because I'm with
Brian I mean it's a complex subject
there's many holes and it takes a lot of
navigation I think what we have to do is
to have a more if we can a more mature
discussion about science in society and
with our political leaders we have to
somehow communicate the strengths of
science the weaknesses of science this
tentative knowledge points that I was
saying that we cannot always say things
with certainty I think one problem is at
school is that science is often taught
with complete certainty and that is a
real difficulty another problem with
school is that we don't focus enough on
the process of science and how you do
good science and so I think we have to
start there in in in educators the 45
second process of science bottom line
that people can take home I think I
prefer to answer the question in terms
of what are the attributes of good
science and the attributes of good
science are respect for good data
observation and reproducible results we
are an empirical activity we have to
have look at the evidence so
we rely on good observations a second is
rational argument simply applying the
logic trying to be as objective that you
can having recognized that we are human
beings and pushed around by our feelings
and by our other beliefs so rational
argument is a second the third is X
skepticism particularly of your own
ideas
so you attack your own ideas and finally
you go through a process that with those
observations you come up with a
hypothesis an idea to explain the
phenomena of interest and then you
attack it
you don't actually try to defend it you
attack it and if it survives sufficient
attacks then you can start thinking how
could there is a vital vital that is
scientists are the most skeptical people
around and yet there is a line that's
out there in the public that somehow
they'll defend a perspective to the
death no we try to kill it every step of
the way and only if it survives every
sledgehammer that we throw at it are we
willing to believe it or have confidence
in it that's a very different process I
just like but here's here's one thing I
think that the analogy Brian between you
and the member of the public breaks down
they're not going to understand anything
that without on their own by poring over
it and they're gonna have to accept much
more as known by science yes then they
could possibly understand they don't
become experts in any area of science
and able to do that they become experts
at figuring out who knows what about
what and they're not even hearing from
scientists they're immersed in social
networks and those two a generally
speaking of a very good job of leading
them to what the truth is but when
they're in social groups that are at
odds with each other they're just doing
the same thing that they ordinarily do
to figure out what science knows and
they really there's no alternative to it
I think the word we practice not using a
Finnish trust when I said we need to
have a more mature discussion and with
society and politics it of course they
cannot understand the science of course
they can't understand what Brian does
but they can trust Brian and they can
trust the process and I think we need to
do the following things we need to focus
on developing trust in science and trust
in scientists and I think in practical
terms we need to work with our
politicians when they disagree
you need to have courteous debate I
don't mean lobbying which actually I
think is perhaps too prevalent
particularly in the u.s. because what do
scientists do they go and see their
politicians when they want more money
you know otherwise they take no notice
of them what we need to do is to make
friends with the politicians and get the
politicians working with scientists to
provide leadership in these sorts of
issues do you see a change in this trust
issue over the course of your career no
I wanted to take that to front well
there's a lot more social media now and
as Dan was saying there's a lot more
places to get once information and
there's a lot more so-called experts
around and and so so that's certainly
people can always pull up or grab on to
something to affirm their beliefs but
there's a vast number of people in the
middle that the bulk of humanity that is
curious even if you have a belief if
you're Murray or more Marsha in the in
the video if if you're a curious Marie
or Marsha you you will be open to having
your your thinking changed with into the
right narratives and and stories about
the research that's being done and so on
and those are the people that that that
I want to address I'd like to give you
an example of something that I did about
a week ago I took nine company nine
congressmen and their staff to Greenland
to the to see the Arctic ice sheet in
Greenland and I think I think everybody
here can appreciate that since it's
covered by ice the whole thing that
we're talking about glaciers receding
and in the sea ice melting and and
environmental change and
on a very big scale that is is
noticeable over the period of just years
and and in the decade and our well I
think the the approach was very much not
just to just to go and see and show them
our facilities there are the kind of
research we're doing and also with other
agencies and when when people can see
for themselves and these these were
congressmen that crossed the spectrum of
you know belief about certain things and
from both sides of the aisle and and I
think it was really revealing without
being at all heavy-handed it just just
going to the different sites and showing
the ice core board down more than a mile
deep and taking samples of emissions of
gases down 150 thousand years ago to the
research on the the ice and the glaciers
and so forth that that they they all
asked a lot of very very good questions
and I think that's that's kind of the
approach that I I think of scientists
just doing more of is is inviting
elected officials to universities to see
their laboratories meet their students
see the kind of research they're doing
have them asked the questions instead of
putting you know putting things and
ideas in front of them and feeding them
is let them feed themselves by being
exposed do you think any mind has
changed on that trip I it's a it's an
excellent question and and I don't know
sometimes one prepares one's mind to
change I'd I'm not sure that that we saw
somebody jump up and have an aha moment
although people did say I need to go
back and read more about this I need to
learn more interesting distinction
between the climate change discussion
here and the discussion over genetically
modified food in the UK is that here the
challenge to the
consensus tends to come from the right
but Paul tell us what's happening with
the question of GMO food in the UK well
it's exactly as you said and in the UK
climate change and the man-made cause is
more or less accepted but there's been
much greater resistance with GM crops
compared with the with the US and this
is really quite interesting and I'm not
sure I can answer it in the general way
that you're asking I can ride what sort
of happened the first thing that
happened is that Monsanto that's the
company who first marketed engineered
Tomatoes was inept and put these adverts
up about how wonderful this all was and
the consumer saw nothing for them they
just saw something for Monsanto secondly
the scientists like me were inept
because when we tried to explain it we
didn't take the rather obvious route of
asking perhaps some of the public what
they thought about this issue
we simply lectured them about how this
was all wonderful in studies that I was
involved in a year later we did ask that
question and you know what the the most
common reply was I was really astonished
the most common reply was that they
didn't want to eat food with genes in it
and it and it is funny of course but
they they they didn't fully appreciate a
good hearty American life and we had
never asked them that question so we
weren't even beginning to be on the same
you know on the same table what's the
answer that you have to talk to the
public to find out can we can we do this
can we clarify what is the scientific
consensus on GM food in the ughhhhh in
the UK in Europe or in or in the world
yeah um the the consensus is that GM is
a technology the scientific consensus is
that GM is a technology that can produce
different outcomes and just like
conventional breeding but what you
should be testing is the final product
to see if it's safe and
and and you safely in the environment I
mean we are GMOs and GMO a human being
is right I mean but we're not how do we
get here right it's just by a slightly
different process yes but we don't eat
ourselves well or at least most of us
yeah maybe you answer they'd be in New
York but the GM modifications were the
produced by normal breathing often
involving by the way hitting those
plants with heavy mutagenesis so you
have no idea what you've done with them
and versus GM modifications so that's
the consensus but the resistance is
partly we're playing God with
manipulating things partly
anti-corporate and big companies cuz
they're making it and once again we're
seeing the politics feed bleeding into
this and partly and this was a tipping
point in the discussion when the media
the newspapers in this case looking for
a you know a good headline so they could
sell another 100,000 we had this
headline in the Daily Mail if it is a
newspaper that's one of the bradford we
have in the UK calling frankenstein
foods it killed the debate for 15 years
it's only now being resurrected and it
is being resurrected now i'm on the
scientific advice mechanism for the
european union we have just produced a
report on on GMOs at the request of the
commission because they are going to now
reappropriation Brian what do you hear
in that story that that in the UK
something that here is incredibly
incredibly blase about GM foods that
over there that's in a sense their
climate change in the sense that the
general public just does not much of the
general public does not trust the
scientists yeah you know it's it's
perhaps hard to predict which issues are
going to raise what sort of thought
process that's going to great resistance
and I guess I don't know Dan do you I
mean is there a
a cultural difference where you can put
your finger on or that is the cause I
mean one thing it makes you conscious of
is that there's a great deal of just
accident and fortuity that creates these
kinds of associations between positions
on facts that admit of scientific
inquiry over space and across time you
see just lots of changes but which ought
to make us realize - that no technology
is destined to have the kind of
resistance that GM foods have in Europe
we should get on top of all the
influences that do steer technologies
down one track or another doing survey
work in case studies to understand why
that happened there and why it hasn't
happened here ultimately will make us
smarter about how to prevent it from
happening as often as it does but do you
advocate I'm just wondering do you
advocate actually looking at a
particular constituency taking a given
scientific idea and packaging it in a
way that somehow will well avoid some of
the the pitfalls that you think are the
cause of why you know the HPV vaccine is
a great example because at the very time
that we were in the midst of this very
contentious political debate about
whether schools should adopt it as a
mandate for stop isn't gonna remind us
what the HPV vaccine is a vaccine that
protects well women but also managed
there's no test for determining whether
men have HPV but they clearly do
contract it and disseminate it that is
extremely common subsidy transmitted
disease that causes cervical cancer um
it's the only vaccine that was proposed
by the CDC for a universal
administration that's not on the list
across the states for mandatory school
enrollment but at the time that we were
having a very bitter contentious fight
about that we also had the HPV vaccine
for hepatitis B hepatitis B is also a
sexually transmitted disease and it
causes actually more cancers than than
HPV at the time it was being
administered to adolescents now it's
administered
infants but there was a ketchup regime
there was no dispute about that you
could to look at HPV and say well it's
bound to have conflict because you're
talking about something about parental
autonomy and about set same thing with
the HPV vaccine the difference was that
people learned about the HPV vaccine
from their doctors they learned about
HPV from watching Fox and MSNBC go at
each other because there was a
legislative proposal to do this usually
it's done by non-political health
administrators and so we should we knew
that was going to happen but it's not
like the evidence was rejected but we
don't have any process for assessing how
these kinds of advances and knowledge
will be presented to the general public
so so to Brian's question you you really
know you need to know where the
accidents gonna have no and and there I
mean you you should be trying to
simulate the conditions under which
people are going to learn about these
new technologies from a medical advance
like the HPV vaccine to other kinds of
things like nanotechnology and the NSF
that's clearly their philosophy let's
learn as much as we can about the kinds
of ways of may of educating people that
are likely to provoke this kind of
polarization and the ones that won't but
John can I just have one more I don't
mean to take the role but just want one
question that comes to mind here so so
if we were to have a better educational
process early on that that kids really
understood what science is about now I
know that they don't there are fantastic
teachers around the country do not get
me wrong this is not fully general but
I've spoke there's so many kids around
the country whose perspective of what
science is is is is memorization get the
facts know the equation that that's all
that it is if the process that that Paul
was talking about was somehow ingrained
really early on could you see that
bubbling up in a way that would mitigate
the issues that you see actually what we
do see as I said is that when an issue
has taken on this kind of status where
the positions are badges of membership
the people who are the most divided
culturally are the ones who are highest
and all of the kinds of critical
reasoning faculties that you are talking
about but does that really
capture an understanding of what science
is and they know that in their bones or
how do you go in the way that really
captures that
oh sure you you have critical reasoning
problems about covariance detection and
conditional probability all kinds of
things not people yeah come on oh I'll
administer the test to you if you like I
want to I want to bring in the audience
for some but now you see you won't but
now is it your cultural view that's
causing you to dismiss is it the culture
of being a science there's a science and
we need a science of science
communication if you're gonna address
these problems whether those
institutions that will use it
we're gonna put some microphones up for
you to line up and ask some questions
but we did ask you the questions when
you came in and here are the results on
the question of whether climate change
is man-made ninety three point four
percent of you said yes on the question
of whether there's something wrong with
GMO food thirty nine point one percent
said yes and whether you support the
burial of nuclear waste forty six
percent said yes I'm curious in light of
the the nuclear the barring nuclear
waste there's scientific consensus that
that's okay the the the National Academy
of Sciences was tearing its hair out
about why the public didn't accept that
long before climate change so that's I
mean it's kind of revealing that this
audience only forty six percent think
that that's safe but you're telling them
that's okay so we can pull them again
then see how influential I'm telling you
that the same groups that don't believe
that make a mistake about scientific
consensus on climate change make the
same make a mistake that consensus on
deep geologic isolation of nuclear waste
if you were to phrase the the nuclear
burial question in terms of do you feels
really strongly about your position I
really wonder if the the data would have
been difficult just quickly do that only
answer if you feel really strongly about
the issue how many people think that
it's okay to deeply bury nuclear waste
and how many people think it's not okay
it's about the same I guess yeah yeah
yeah do we have any questions yet
because we have some coming in from
online from YouTube from Laurie Brummett
she's asking what are ways in which
these panelists are
working to change the public perceptions
of science or should people with
influence and power be doing something
to change the perceptions want to take
that to you Brian we're not doing
anything
no just the world science foundation
yeah no that's what this festival it is
right so so what you know it's not that
every scientist should be out there
talking to the public I think there's
some whose time is better spent just in
the laboratory doing the work right but
but those who are interested in doing it
and those who feel called to do it I
think many are going out and and
speaking to the public look when we
started this festival there is
definitely that was 10 years ago
there is definitely some uncertainty on
the part of some scientists about do I
want to be part of this do I want to be
out there in the public now we have
scientists all year round lobbying to be
part of the festival so there's a change
in perspective that getting out there
and talking to the public is important
and really matters and I think
culturally we even see it right now I
mean again let me just be personal about
it a couple years ago I would not be on
this panel the only thing I'd ever talk
about is this subject that I work on as
a scientist and now I feel moved to be a
little bit more broad because we see
what's happening in the world and we
have to step up and do something about
it we even see scientists now there's a
new group of scientists who are pledging
to run for public office right used to
be no no we stay away from that but now
going forward
[Music]
France I see a lot of nodding from you
on that part I see a lot of nodding from
you on well yeah I mean we we are
embracing uncertainty a lot more and
being an uncomfortable and challenging
situations my agency spends over sixty
million dollars a year funding what we
call advancing informal science learning
and that's money that goes to public
broadcasting stations it goes to museums
it goes to science festivals and and
that's that's all to try to do better
about the public communication of
science and and these events are widely
widely attended I mean some of our
museums in this country have millions of
visitors a year that want to do hands-on
science let's go to a question man hi
there we have a problem with the global
warming and you know it's all producers
and people like that that are making
that a big problem but we also have
nuclear weapons and that's the other big
thing that could annihilate the planet
and civilization and we wouldn't have
them if it weren't for scientists the
question is what a scientists doing
about it how are they able we don't have
linus pauling anymore Joseph Rotblat who
are the scientists that will speak up or
say something about their colleagues who
are making these things okay I think
that's a really important thing you want
trust it's a good question let's take it
to first to a Paul you're on the spot um
well I was a member of CND who actually
campaign for nuclear disarmament the
scientists do speak out about speak
against the use of nuclear arms it is of
course a personal opinion so it's not
actually to do with science it to do
with the use of yes and it's just like
any other member of the public so in
fact some will be speak against it and
some not if the question was which it
sort of got close to saying without
scientific understanding we wouldn't
have nuclear weapons and so is that an
attack on
scientific understanding well I would
say without science we wouldn't have
many many other things and I think that
isn't the right way to think about it
science gives you the knowledge it's the
use of the knowledge the use of wouldn't
have nuclear facts or something like
that either
but science produces the knowledge
society after determine how that
knowledge is used thank you for that
question very provocative question for
over here hi you guys earlier talked a
little bit about uncertainties that are
inherent to and perhaps well understood
by scientific consensus things like
uncertainties and confidence intervals
but there have been plenty of cases in
the past where science has been just
flat-out wrong whether that's because
there's some element we didn't
understand or perhaps there's some
methodology that we're picking up some
sort of noise so to play devil's
advocate a little bit I was wondering
what you guys think the probability is
that we're wrong about something like
climate change and whether or not we
should accept some amount of humility
about that well I emphasize that we
should look upon science as a spectrum
that there is tentative knowledge and
this firmer knowledge and I think that's
really where it is and there's different
areas that you can put different
probabilities to and our responsibility
is really to communicate that
uncertainty and that probability I think
we should be wary of thinking when a
piece of research turn or an idea turns
out to be wrong as if that is just
entirely negative because it isn't as we
touched on before science moves by this
process of being wrong about things
which then cleans out certain ideas so I
do I do think that we have to be a
little more open about the fact that
there will be mistakes made in science
and that's part of the process and I'm
not talking about fraud or anything like
that it's just that we make observations
they may not be accurate in a certain
way we may have an idea and they don't
take everything on but that is just the
process of Saucer before you leave the
mica
I'm curious to know whether you found
that answer satisfying I think I was
thinking more of results such as the
recent
bicep results which we all know we're
about primordial gravitation as an
example because it's easier to speak of
since it takes it out of the political
realm so here is a result that was
announced okay
incredibly exciting that we might have
detected Graham can you can you catch
everybody else so a few years ago before
the recent discovery that was announced
February 11th of 2016 that we had
finally discovered gravitational waves
there was a previous announcement by a
team at the South Pole that they thought
they found indirect evidence for the
existence of gravitational waves it got
the world of science incredibly excited
and the data looked kind of strong but
over the course of just a few days to
weeks scientists converged on this and
began to raise issues at Columbia within
a few days we had a group meeting where
experts said well we don't know it may
be dust and forth they didn't talk about
four grounds in the paper and and so the
community came together and within a
year it was determined that the
interpretation of the data was incorrect
that it wasn't gravitational waves
that's beautiful
that's not something bad that's the
ability of science to self-correct
that's the beauty of it all
[Music]
and and just to emphasize that when that
result came out I made a big poster
picture on dry mounted it of the the B
polarization background map the famous
one that then turned out to be incorrect
or was actually mapping dust in our own
galaxy and I take that out and show it
to visitors every once in a while like
that is one of my favorite favorite
stories of the progress of science the
people that wrote the paper man I feel
exactly collectively the community we're
talking about here over here so recently
there have been there was a book and
also several articles which dealt with
the reproducibility crisis in biomedical
research and I'm wondering whether you
panel think that that is something which
is gonna hurt science in the public
perception generally and what we should
do about that I think I've got to catch
that one yes yes reproducibility
particularly in medical science actually
I've got a few comments to me the first
thing is that the biological research is
made with biological material biological
material is often very variable and some
of this reproducibility issue is around
the fact that you're not always working
with exactly the same things and because
of that biological variability a second
aspect to this is that some of the the
techniques that are being used are very
sophisticated and complicated and can be
difficult to actually reproduce there is
a something that's growing up but if
somebody says this and then somebody
doesn't get the same result this person
is always wrong that isn't actually
necessarily the case this person might
be wrong it is part of actually the
process then there's a third aspect of
it which is the one that is spoken about
most which is that people that
it's making it up and it's fake science
and they're trying to make money and
they're driving things through and there
is no question in my mind that there is
some pressures in this direction
pressures for people's careers to get
interesting results to get interesting
papers sometimes it's commercial
interests and my view about that is is
that we simply have to have a good
culture in scientific research where
that is simply not acceptable it's
acceptable to make genuine mistakes
because that that will happen sometimes
it is not acceptable to be sloppy in the
work it's not acceptable to be
fraudulent I sum it up science is a high
calling and I'm not sure we emphasize
enough it is a high calling and we have
to hold ourselves to high standards
you
[Music]